♫ Where do we go from here? ♫
♫ How do we carry on? ♫
♫ I can't get beyond the questions ♫
♫ Clambering for the scraps ♫
♫ in the shatter of us, collapsed ♫
♫ It cuts me with every could have been ♫
♫ Pain on pain on play, repeating ♫
♫ With the backup, makeshift life in waiting ♫
♫ Everybody says ♫
♫ time heals everything ♫
♫ What of the wretched hollow? ♫
♫ The endless in between? ♫
♫ Are we just going to wait it out? ♫
♫ There is nothing to see here now ♫
♫ Turning the sign around ♫
♫ We're closed to the Earth 'til further notice ♫
♫ A crumbling cliche case ♫
♫ crumpled and puffy faced ♫
♫ caught dead in the stare of a thousand miles ♫
♫ All I want, only one street level miracle ♫
♫ I'll be an out and out born again ♫
♫ from none more cynical ♫
♫ Everybody says ♫
♫ that time heals everything ♫
♫ But what of the wretched hollow? ♫
♫ The endless in between? ♫
♫ Are we just going to wait it out? ♫
♫ And sit here cold? ♫
♫ We will be long gone by then ♫
♫ In lackluster ♫
♫ In dust we lay around old magazines ♫
♫ Fluorescent lighting sets the scene ♫
♫ for all we could and should be being ♫
♫ in the one life that we've got ♫
♫ Everybody says ♫
♫ time heals everything ♫
♫ And what of the wretched hollow? ♫
♫ The endless in between? ♫
♫ Are we just going to wait it out? ♫
♫ Just going to sweat it out? ♫
♫ Wait it out ♫
(Applause)